everybody's closing down their shop
because they're burnt out and they have
no heart left if you measure everything
oh I Gotta Be A Millionaire to be con
considered successful you're an idiot
it's like owning a hardware store I want
to be Home Depot you don't have to be
Home Depot
you can be the small hardware store on
the on on Main Street and do just fine
and make a living and be known to
everybody in the town just the same way
as Home Depot because you're doing what
you like you have passion you love being
that small shop I am not driven I got a
top single hit I'm not interested never
was I wanted to be the band that existed
on on a Underground Level for 40 years
and then on their their 50th year when
they're just about finished they put out
a top top 10 Hit album it sounds like
like crazy now you're retired you have
to ask yourself why you're doing it
you're doing it because it's fulfilling
your your soul that's what you're driven
to do that's what what I do